England has been the country that's led
the way in virtually everything we
invented modernity in the late 17th
century the Industrial Revolution and
all the rest right and one of the very
peculiar features about England which I
think has become a kind of disease which
is spread to the rest of the West is the
self-hatred in English intellectual I
mean it's written about very very
interestingly by George Orwell you'll
remember that just immediately before
and well on either side of the and
second world war in which is that
wonderful passage describing the kind of
people who read The Guardian you know
sandal the sandal-wearing quakerage
classes veggie or invariably vegetarian
or vegan as the kind of people who would
rather steal from the poor box than
stand to sing the national anthem and
that again it goes back to the late 19th
century you've got in the Mikado's
wander in Coco's song in The Mikado of
all the people that he hated it's those
who it's those who sing the praises of
every century but this and every country
but their own and this has become
profoundly deep rooted in anglo-saxon
culture it was I think essentially
snobbery
I mean English roots utterly disgusting
no you really really must eat French
food a theme you've got absolutely will
you give an example absolutely no sense
of style or dress you illustrate the
answer and then of course it becomes
given an extra crank and edge by race
sensitivity and so it now shifts from
snobbery to something else which is that
we of course as imperialists are
responsible for absolutely all the ills
in the world and then of course not only
did we have an empire we had slavery and
so every other culture in the world
including China hadn't I did not have
slavery and in fact the peculiar thing
about the British Empire is that it may
be built on slavery but it then actually
spends more money on eradicate
that it ever made from it and then of
course the slavery you can then turn
across the Atlantic because until very
recently what was very striking about
America
was right or left a passionate
patriotism but suddenly in America with
race politics and slavery you're using
these things to discredit even the
American ideal even the American
Revolution even the American Declaration
of Independence because of course the
American Declaration of Independence we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that men are born free and equal with
you know certain rights given by the
divinity and whatever by the Creator and
you have slavery so there is indeed a
fundamental hypocrisy and you're using
that and the left is using that to
devastating effect to lead to a
rejection of your own civilization and
to see it as being responsible for all
the ill in the world was the plain truth
is that the West and capitalism if you
value health if you value education if
you value security of life have created
a civilization which offers incomparable
II more of these things to an
incomparably larger percentage of the
population than has ever ever been the
case before but then you know what we
take it for granted
[Music]